I kind of related to or or or felt I
could understand this this girl who's
grown up with the seemingly caring
parents who inadvertently you know give
their child a a recipe for narcissism in
in in creating this fictional sibling
for her Amazing Amy you know who's a
sort of sweet cartoon but one who's
always better than her more accomplished
than her succeeds every time real Amy
fails and and so I think you've got this
little girl who grows up with a with a a
sort of Fame she never earned and is
made to be the face of this cartoon um
and so simultaneously feels entitled and
really insecure and I sort of think well
where does that little girl what does
that little girl turn into when she
becomes an adult and she's so at ease
with sort of putting on appearances that
that she can just sort of shapeshift and
and and be whatever's required by the
situation and it's really unrelaxing